فهو المعتد المتحدي والمنتقد تختلف
اطلالته هذه المره فيطل عبر شبكه سي ان ان
في اول ظهور لهم منذ العام 2016 على
الشبكه اطلاله يقول خبراء انها محسوبه
جيدا في توقيتها ومكانها استثمرها ترامب
انتخابيا واطلق سهامه في كل الاتجاهات
رئيس السابق جدد رفضه الاعتراف بخساره
الانتخابات الرئاسيه امام جو بايدن
واصل انتقاداته لاداره بايدن ازمه سقف
الدين العام كانت حاضره ما نفعله الان
اننا ننفق المال مثل البحاره المخمورين
خارجيا والى الحرب في اوكرانيا يثق الرئيس
السابق بقدرته على وقف الحرب وبسرعه سافعل
ذلك في غضون 24 ساعه انت بحاجه الى قوه
الرئاسه للقيام بذلك لكن ماذا عن موقفه ان
كان يريد لاوكرانيا الانتصار ام لا افكر
فيما يتعلق بالفوز والخساره اعتقد من
ناحيه يجب تسويه الامر حتى نتوقف عن قتل
كل هؤلاء الاشخاص لقاء جدد فيه ترامب
مواقفه وعادته في مهاجمه الجميع حتى
المذيعه طالها من الانتقادات نصيب لست
شخصا جيدا لا تعلمين عما تتحدثين ينتهي
اللقاء فيسارع الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
الى التعليق قائلا هل تريدون فعلا اربع
سنوات اخرى من هذا اذا كنتم لا تريدون ذلك
فساهموا في حملتنا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات